using the Zeke headphones from parrot
the same company that brought us those
remote-controlled quadcopters that
you've probably seen before now these
are wireless noise cancelling headphones
and just looking at them you can tell
they're quite handsome and they're quite
attractive and they're probably several
hundred dollars but the magic doesn't
end there the secret is that these
headphones are packed with sensors the
entire surface of the right ear cup is
touch sensitive so to change the volume
you just touch it run your finger up to
go down in volume you just run your
finger down to go between tracks you
either swipe forwards towards the front
of your head or backwards towards the
back of your head to pause the music you
just tap you can also tap in the ear cup
to answer an incoming phone call and
when you're talking on the phone the
five noise cancelling microphones and
outside start picking up your voice also
on the inside of the right earcup there
is a small bone conducting headphone
that will pick up the vibrations of your
jawbone to make it easier for the person
you're talking to to hear what you're
saying inside the left earcup there's an
NFC chip so if you have an NFC
compatible smartphone like this galaxy
nexus you just tap the phone to the ear
cup you'll get a little alert on your
phone screen showing you that there's a
device recognized you just tap on that
little alert on your phone and then your
headphones and your phone are paired and
you're ready to start talking on the
phone and you're ready to start
listening to the music that's coming out
of your phone now my favorite feature is
the head sensor when you've got them on
your head and you're listening to music
and somebody comes up to you and wants
to interrupt your good time by talking
to you you just slide them around your
neck the headphones will recognize the
fact that they're not on your head
anymore and the musical stop it's really
cool to start it back up just put them
back on your head and the music starts
up takes about a second but it works
like a charm every time so their
wireless Bluetooth noise cancelling
headphones how do they sound not
fantastic they sound pretty good and
I've wore them for about three or four
days and tested them extensively and
they sounded pretty good to my ears but
you can still kind of hear some of the
digital artifacts from the noise
cancelling and if you're a bit of a
stickler for audio quality that'll
probably be enough of a pain point for
you to stay away but if you like the
design you like having all this really
cool technology which does make the
headphones a lot easier to you
and a lot easier to walk around with and
control then you should definitely check
them out I recommend them